now let me say something let me say
something okay i'm rooting for the
dodgers
i you know they're due they've suffered
enough disappointment
i love me some mookie bets i i've always
hated the clayton kershaw narrative
so let's be clear i'm looking for the
dodgers to take this thing
that's what i want to happen but there's
another side of me though
that would derive great pleasure
from watching that head of yours explode
if the tampa bay rays were to somehow
win this series at minimum make it a
long series because yesterday oh my god
you were
when they sweep when they're closing
this out in game four
they could bring back kershaw oh my god
so
yeah yeah um yeah what you got now i
can't even i can't even name you
minnie ray's um i know brandon that's
the problem
i know brandon i know brandon lowe hit
two home runs
last night and i only know that because
i read it today i
ought to do it because i read it he had
two home runs last night
and he broke out of a 656 post-season
slump it is 1-1
baby and so this may be in real time i
may be jumping on the raised bandwagon
right
now michael because i just i i just want
the troll in me
if the troll in me has been awakening
and inspired because you know what
michael hey let me at the floor for a
second
because you know you know what's going
on you got it you got it you know what's
up you know it's an underreported story
you know what people don't talk enough
about the discrepancy
in payroll is gargantuan between these
two teams
i mean how in the world this scrappy
undermanned little team that could
tampa bay ray's squad taking on
this goliath look at those payroll
numbers michael nobody's talking about
this michael
nobody's talking about this and i don't
understand why
i don't understand why people are
overlooking the fact
that the rays really don't belong here
nobody believed in them i don't care
that they were 40 and 20. nobody
believed in this team
look at that it goes to show you that a
smart organization
you're a jerk man like really that's
really like a lot of jerk in you
i said earlier this week remember
earlier this week i said you're a nicer
person
i say that you're a nicer person i got
nothing else but you're not a nicer
person
you're not a nicer person tonight i mean
seriously i mean i don't
i don't know you can talk enough about
that michael i don't know that you can
talk enough about the difference in
payroll i don't i think that's an
underplayed there
have you ever heard you ever heard
somebody say like about a city
let's say you like a city you ever hear
anybody say i love the city
i wish i had different people you know
like tampa tampa
i like to play i like the players
i like the players and i might even like
people in management and oh i might
but it's just the way their story is
told i like the players i just hate
their story
and you mentioned you said very
poignantly you said
oh i can't even name a few uh uh i can
only name a few rays
that's part of the problem it's almost
like the play it's not about the players
it's not about the players
the tampa bay raids being here they they
should be out there in briony suits
they're not out there in uniforms those
are the front the front office is on the
field
those players are just proxies for the
front office these players haven't done
anything you throw any players in there
because of the brainiacs
in the front office who have made all
this happen let me read you can i just
read you a quote just a quote
from your former employer your former
employer
espn shame of themselves wrote this
story about
how the rays are changing baseball
forever they have changed baseball
i love teams to change their sport
without winning a championship anyway
i'm just reading the line miss kennedy
lonti uh
despite a payroll that ranks 28th in
major league baseball
who knew ahead of just the pittsburgh
pirates and the baltimore orioles
that philosophy along with a reputation
for
outsmarting other teams in trades
and tactics has long brought the rays
respect
now it has brought them back to the
world series for the first time in a
dozen years
like you know what um i just can't yeah
i'm i like the players
great guys i cannot have them win they
cannot win
and look if they have to go seven if it
has to go seven so be it
the dodgers you must win this do this
for me please win this for me yeah
please i would i would you know what you
know what i wouldn't be in a good for i
would not
be a good friend if i did not root for
the raise at this point
i would not i would be doing our
relationship in this show with the
service
if i didn't just go ahead and jump on
randy or rosarina what's it uh
is that did i say it right a rosary look
at you yeah right you're trying to get
the rookie that's hidden names right i'm
working on it i'm working on it dude i
told you i won't be paying attention no
more
listen don't let me go down that path
okay bottom line is he's good
and i'm gonna get a jersey i'm gonna get
a randy a rosarian jersey
just and i'm aware to the show and i'm
repping the rays
through the rest of the the this playoff
series
the rest of this playoff series you just
forgot in fact
in fact how about that two check would
you take that would you take two
champions in tampa you take that you
want you want the be you want the bucks
to win so bad why you can't get on the
raise bandwagon
no the bucks are different the bucks are
different like nobody nobody says all
right they're like
i'm sorry the lightning
for the bucks as well though right i i
want the bucks to win i like the bucks
yeah yeah low-key yeah
but no i can't i can't deal with this i
can't deal with the raise um
but i i do i do like what they bring to
table see
there's a different story to be told
with the raise that's
intriguing they are it's almost like
if you wanted to switch up sports so in
in football we always talk about it
being a passing league right
it's a passing league and we're just
used to that
then here comes somebody if somebody
came along with a
pure running old-school offense
and won the super bowl defense and and
running
game we'd say oh man that's the
throwback the tampa bay rays if you look
at the way they built their team they're
a throwback team
they're not blessed with tons of
offensive talent but they got a great
pitching staff
and and they make smart decisions on the
field on the field the players the
players the actual players
do a good job but we don't get that
story all we get is about their little
payroll and
their smart their wall street front
office please don't win
please please all right all right listen
i i just i just derive such a joy
such joy give me this one from from from
your pain and i told you
it listen i i love mookie but
my priority is is uh is poking in front
of you
that's my priority at this point they've
changed baseball settle in
they've changed baseball forever forever
it's right there long story long story
about how they changed the game
you